today is a very special place or class
in cs109 because this is the first class
where we're actually going to be talking
about probabilities about time we're a
class on probability for computer
scientists so get excited we will get
deep into what probability actually
means today
before we jump into anything though a
couple announcements this is a fun thing
hey I like to tell stories on Fridays
just one of the things I do so I'm going
to tell you guys a short story to get
our class started uh important
announcement much more important than
the Friday announcement is that section
signups are open and they're going to be
open until Sunday at noon you have
between now and Sunday at noon to fill
in your section time preferences at
which point we'll close the queue so you
want to make sure you get signed up
before then it's not first come first
serve but just make sure you hit that
deadline
some of you guys have not seen python
before or you just like a refresher
there will be an online review session
at five o'clock today on Friday uh you
can go check it out it will be recorded
and we will post the recording uh within
a reasonable time but if you can go live
fantastic
and then finally
we're gonna do something today that's
never been done before I promise you
something completely unique in the world
will happen by the end of lecture
but quickly story time you know there's
a lot of stories I can tell but maybe an
interesting one is a lot of people ask
me why did I grow up in Kenya and
Malaysia and of course the answer is my
parents they brought me to well I was
born in Kenya but I lived there because
they chose to live there and so the
question really becomes why did my
parents end up living in Kenya and
Malaysia and the story was my parents
were my mom had grown up in Europe and
my dad had grown up in Philadelphia and
then they met one day and the story of
the meeting is kind of cute I guess my
dad was a high school teacher and during
the summer he went on a trip and my mom
went on a trip in the same direction
they met uh fell in love
but they're living two different cities
Boston Philadelphia at the time and they
were doing long-distance relationships
they're like um maybe we should find
some place to live together so on like a
date they thought you know what we
should do it would be funny we should
apply to jobs in different corners of
the world just to see what would happen
and so they applied to jobs in like
Brazil and France uh and all these
different places and they got a response
back from a job in Jordan that was for
both of them and they're like you guys
could go live in the Middle East my dad
like never left Philadelphia uh and so
they're like
okay let's go and the I guess well
technically the story went they had sent
a check in the mail this is like in the
early 80s uh and they cashed the checks
spent the money and then they're like
wait we can't do this but they'd already
spent the money and they couldn't return
the camera that they bought so they went
they're like we'll go to Jordan for a
year
um but they went to Amman for a year and
when they're in a month they had an
incredible experience and they met some
Kenyan people who said hey if you like
Amman You're Gonna Love Nairobi so you
can come and you can teach over there so
they thought they'd only be gone for a
year they didn't sell any of their
things
um they got married over like two days
notice and then went on and they said
we'll call this our honeymoon and then
you know when we're done with this we'll
come back to the States uh but the just
it never stopped for them they went to
Kenya and they were there for about 15
years and then they went to Malaysia uh
and they were there until earlier last
year and the cutest thing is like if you
ask my dad about he'd be like yeah just
the honeymoon never ended which I think
is just very adorable
also adorable section signups how do you
do it you go to section sign up form you
get a form like this you have hard
questions like what is your name and
what is your availability of time
problem sets out as you know problem set
one has been out since Wednesday
a couple frequently asked questions is
there's that cool check answer feature
it's fantastic you can know if you're
doing anything right I think somebody
asked this and it's just worth repeating
can you check many times absolutely yeah
there's not a penalty for a checking
many times
um are you just going to grade us on
whether or not you get a green check
mark no you have to give explanations
for all of your answers so even if you
check your answer you get the right
number please explain your work because
it's the process of explaining your work
that we really care about and it is
important that you guys learn the way of
expressing ideas in this subject not
just getting the right answers how much
explanation should we provide we talked
about this on Wednesday but certainly
looking at work examples gives you an
idea of what it should look like
um do you have to do all your work on
the app no absolutely you could do it by
hand take a photo upload the photo
whatever you want to do
um to get your answers
example answer of like what sort of
explanation we want is check out the
ignig machine this is a question and
here's the sort of level of detail we'd
like to see in an answer
super small thing about half the class
has started this is how many questions
people have finished so like some people
have finished between zero and four some
people between four and six six and
eight eight and twelve and ten and you
know like there's even a small number of
people who did the whole problem Set uh
about half the class has already started
and I would encourage if you haven't
already started to get started as soon
as possible after today's class you'll
be able to do every problem on that
first problem set so if you want to be
done by Sunday and then just party the
rest of week two you absolutely could do
that
uh okay in Python review session you
know is going to be online and you can
find the link on the website
that's all we have for Logistics any
questions before we jump into content
okay
we oh yeah question
yes two of the sections are going to be
online
uh it might depend on demand so for the
people who want online sessions I think
you might be setting the time based on
that demand good question
to do
we don't have to book rooms for online
okay
so in our last great class we did
counting and not easy counting like
pretty serious counting and we did three
particular versions of counting that
we're going to build upon today the
three types of counting that we did last
class is we talked about let's say you
have n items how could you think about
different ways of counting sortings of
those items so orderings of those where
order really matters and we need a
different task which is like let's say
you have n items how many ways could you
choose a subset of K and that's a
different task because in this case we
don't really care about the ordering of
the subset you choose just we care about
which items were chosen in the subset
and a third task we look into is let's
say you have n items how many ways could
you put them into say our buckets
in each of these cases we often thought
about distinct versus indistinct
um and what I want to point out though
is we had a distinct case for each of
those and that's what you really need to
know to take counting into probability
Theory you want to know how to do
sorting for distinct items you want to
feel very comfortable with how you can
choose K subset from n distinct items
and you want to do the bucketing with
n-distinct items we're going to use them
today to the point where I wrote those
three rules out on the board
and I just instead of having our buckets
I had K buckets
okay
a little bit of warm up to get us going
back into the mindset of counting
I have this whole Narrative of if you
wanted to do something like make a DNA
tree there's lots of calculations like
this that require you to do a comparison
between every one of n different
elements so in this case I'm going to
give you n animals and you need to do a
calculation for every pair of animals
for this problem I don't want you to
worry about what the calculation is I
want you to count how many calculations
there are so n atom and animals and I
want you to do a calculation for every
pair how many calculations do you have
to do
does that question make sense
and Adam and I want you to think about
it so if you have an idea if
clarification questions ask them now if
you have an idea tell it to the person
next to you clarification questions
before you jump in yes
yes okay so let's say you have an atom
animals we have all of these different
animals
and I want to count how many pair unique
pairs of animals are there so like this
is a pair of animals but this is a
different pair of animals and this is a
different pair of animals so how many
pairs of animals are there and there's a
story here if you want to make like a
DNA tree of all those animals you'd have
to do a DNA comparison between every
pair
good question
making sense
okay take a moment talk about it with
the person next to you let's see how
many different pairs of animals are
there
okay
just a warm up
I like this problem for a few reasons
one I've just needed as a computer
scientist there's been many many times
in my life where I had to do this
calculation and I had to pause to decide
how long would my calculation take and
sometimes the sort of work could take
you know a couple hours of compute and
so you want to be thoughtful about how
many comparisons you have to do I also
like it because there's several
different ways of coming up with an
answer
did anyone find a way to solve this
problem just by directly inferring one
of these rules
yes in the back
okay
let's just uh you're choosing uh you're
choosing two animals out of the how many
there are one
n
we don't like to count past seven
okay if you if you counted this way see
your n choose two will you ever end up
with animal a with itself
no it doesn't give you n choose two is
always thinking about you have these N
Things that I'm always going to get two
distinct items in N choose two do you
get if you get
um this first and then that second will
you get a different outcome which has
them reversed
no okay yeah in N choose two we think of
the items as distinct but we don't care
about the ordering once you've chosen
them
so n choose two is exactly it there is
another way of thinking about it
a cool way of thinking about it is you
can imagine this grid
and here let's say you have animals a b
c and here you have animals ABC
we're not going to check out anything on
the diagonal
but we are going to do a and b
and we are going to do a and C
and then for B we've already compared
with a
we're not going to compare B with itself
but we are going to do c and for C you
know where we've already compared it
with a and we've already compared it
with b and you just kind of have these
three different comparisons so if there
was three animals three choose two would
actually have given you three
but if you took this up to more
you can imagine okay it's n minus 1 plus
n minus 2 every you're going to count
how many things are in this upper right
triangle
and I think it's really interesting that
for n choose two those two lead to the
same answer
um
okay just not that important right now
but just for n choose two if you counted
how many things are in the upper right
hand triangle if you made that equation
you'd be able to prove that's equivalent
to what this is if you were to decompose
it so n factorial divided by K factorial
times n minus K factorial
okay that was just our brief little
warm-up so really you want to feel very
comfortable with these three counting
tasks uh going forward
and I know it's not easy counting is
surprisingly difficult but you guys seem
to be doing very well considering how
hard I know it is
okay and this is a small deal but
um you know when I was doing my PhD the
person who's sitting next to me they
were doing this research problem in
computer science where they were taking
um samples of people's cancer cells and
then they were doing this and choose to
comparisons of the actual DNA to come up
with evolutionary trees of how cancer
was evolving within people and it led to
incredible research and now it's
something that people are seeing
um in medical diagnosis for actually
helping people's prognoses so fun little
Side Story this stuff could be helpful
well I guess you're just counting on my
calculations you do but that's also
helpful too
okay
the probability I need to just introduce
you to two terms and these two terms are
ones that we're going to evoke a lot and
once you feel comfortable with these
terms then we can really talk about what
a probability is
the first term I'd like to introduce you
to is this term of a sample space I want
to get really formal about talking about
all of the outcomes of an experiment
so let's say my experiment is flipping
this ridiculously large coin look how
big that is
it's got one head and one tail
if you think about flipping this coin
there's two different outcomes we could
get you can get a heads or a tails and
to be really formal that set which has
all the outcomes we call that the sample
space so if you want to say the sample
space of flipping this coin it's heads
and tails the size of that sample space
is two
now if you had two coins
you know the sample space could be heads
heads Heads Tails Tails heads Tails
tails you can Define your sample space
like that
what if you had a six-sided dice what
are all the outcomes of a six-sided dice
we have like one two three four five six
all those different outcomes we think of
the sample space if your experiment was
rolling in dice
just to be clear sample spaces don't
have to be
um
they can be infinitely large so for
example the number of emails in the day
how many emails could you get in a day
can't be negative you can get zero Ah
that's what we call a good day uh one
email is possible and and you know 999
999 is also possible any positive
integer is a possible outcome of the
experiment of seeing how many emails you
got in a day
so the sample space all possible
outcomes it doesn't have to be uh it can
be infinitely large
similarly it can be continuous so your
experiment could be how many you two or
I'm going to look in a day and count how
many YouTube hours I've watched in a day
and YouTube hours could be a continuous
number instead of being like two it
could be 2.345 so sounds people say says
the outcomes
we have this formal language it can be
infinite it can be real numbered yes
in the Tipping two coins yeah I think in
this case I'd like to think as this is
coin one and this is coin two so this is
coin one is a head coin two is ahead
coin one's ahead coin two is a tail very
good question
okay so sample space it's just the
formal name that we give to all the
outcomes of an experiment
which leads to the other terms I want to
familiarize with it which is the event
space if you run an experiment sometimes
there's a thing you care about an event
that you care about for example flipping
a coin maybe the event you care about is
that you have a heads so there's just
one outcome in the event space that's
getting ahead getting a tail doesn't
give you a head maybe the thing that you
care about is whether or not you got
more than one head on your two coin
flips and so all three of these events
so head on the first coin head on the
second coin or head on the first coin's
tail and second coin or tail on the
first coin head on the set point those
three events those three outcomes
satisfy that idea of getting more than
one head on two coin flips so Advanced
space is some subset of the sample space
that satisfies something semantic
something that we can name like getting
more than one heads on two coins
here's another example we talked about
the experiment of rolling a dice and
there's six outcomes but maybe three of
them satisfy the event of getting a
three or less on the coin so one two or
three
a number of emails days being less than
20. you know that could be the event
that you're looking for and that could
be that subset of the sample space that
you care about or for example you could
Define a wasted day to be more than five
YouTube hours and we've all been there
at some point uh and then you can say
that's the subset of the sample space
that I care about
Okay so
sample space event space some
terminology at some point lecture I'll
use those terms and feel free to
interrupt me like hey can you remind me
Chris what you meant by event space you
remind me what you meant by sample space
so just to put that on one slide you
know you have sample space all the
outcomes of the experiment and the event
space how many of those satisfy some
semantic event
okay yeah
the Subspace the sample space all the
possible outcomes are the numbers it's
all it's all the possible outcomes yeah
and we can talk about the size of it you
can ask how many things are in here and
we'll often ask that question but when
we say the sample space we mean all the
outcomes themselves good question very
good question and that's why I use the
capital S capital S is for a set and
then I often use a lowercase number if I
was just talking about a number
would have thought that an event is an
item of the set but it seems like an
event is a subset is there like a name
or a term for like terminology for one
individual item inside the sample quiz
yeah we call that one outcome so this is
one outcome this is one outcome this is
one outcome and this is a set of
outcomes that we give a semantic meaning
to that's a great great question
not semantically nitpicky at all
okay
are you guys ready to find out what a
probability really is
okay a probability is very simply going
to be a number between 0 and 1. to which
we're going to ascribe meaning towards
um and I'll tell you a little bit more
about that when we get into philosophy
later in today's class
um but let's say you talk about a
probability an event occurring
we can write it as P of e and that says
what's the probably this event occurring
again this is like the events that we
just talked about in the previous slide
sometimes you'll see different notation
like PR of e it's the same thing but
just like a little bit faster and these
people could be like I'm so fancy right
now but that's not important there's
still this is indication for a
probability
and even though it's a number between
zero and one that we ascribe meaning to
there was a moment about 150 years ago
when people started to formalize what
they really meant when they talked about
a probability
when we talk about a probability of an
event
imagine you were to repeat infinite
experiments so there'll be infinite
times that you'd roll your dice
what's the ratio between number of times
that those experiments led to your event
divided by the number of experiences
you've run
so as you approach Infinity how does
this ratio what does this ratio approach
in the limit
so lots lots of experiments as it gets
to Infinity the ratio of successes to
number experience you run that's what we
really mean by a probability
to make this a little bit concrete
let's say n is the number of times I run
a trial in this case I'm going to be
throwing a dart at this board
the event is that I hit the target when
we give this primal definition of what a
probability is
intuitively it's saying we're going to
not run one experiment in this case I
threw one Dart and it didn't hit the
board so the probability looks like it's
a zero don't run two experiments in this
case that Dart did hit the board so you
can say I've run two experiments one of
which is hit the board so that ratio is
0.5 this definition like as that
probability or as the number of
experiments tends towards Infinity this
ratio is going to tend towards what we
Define to be the probability
that's kind of a wild one but it's one
to nice it's a nice thing to have in
your back pocket
now I will complicate this a little bit
in that we talk about probabilities in
lots of ways and in fact thinking about
probabilities and where they come from
and being really expansive in your ideas
of it was one of the things that allowed
for Revolutions in computer science in
the 90s and the 2000s
so here is another way of thinking about
probability is that I find is very in
tune with the philosophy of cs109
imagine you're a self-driving car
and you want to think about whether or
not there's a motorcycle next to you
this is a really interesting thing
because the motorcycles either there or
it's not there
however for a self-driving car to make a
smart decision under uncertainty
it recognizes not that there is
uncertainty in the world but there's
uncertainty in my own understanding of
the world there's uncertainty in the
car's own understanding of whether or
not there's a motorcycle
so beyond just thinking about a
probabilities as being there is still
Cassidy in the world and we can think
about infinite events
a modern view of probability is thinking
not just that there's still Cassie in
the world but there's uncertainty in
ourselves and probability is a language
for expressing that we do not know
and that makes it much more powerful
it's not stochastic there's a motorcycle
or there's not a motorcycle but this car
has to hold a belief about whether or
not there's a motorcycle because the car
doesn't have perfect information so to
me a probability is much more than just
their stochasty in the world it is
representation of what I don't know
but still a number between zero and one
to which we have scribe meaning and it's
still the case that from the car's
perspective let's say it had a 0.9
probability that there's a motorcycle
there the way I would interpret that
point nine as say you know if this car
was to live the situation infinite times
ninety percent of those times you would
in fact have a motorcycle there so it is
a very elegant language both for
expressing just there's Randomness in
our world but also we don't know things
cool philosophy Philosophy for a Friday
okay any questions about this you're
like there's like this goes even deeper
like is our world really stochastic in
any way shape or form uh but that
requires like a glass of wine to get
into
there's lots of sources of probabilities
one of the sources of probability is you
can derive them mathematically there's
things in the world where we can use
pencil and paper and figure out exactly
what probabilities are there are other
sources of probability sometimes we get
probabilities from data sometimes we can
get probabilities from doing lots of
experiments uh but the one we're going
to focus on at the beginning of class is
the ones that we can just know perfectly
from paper and that will build us some
intuition for when we expand our ideas
of sources of probability to things like
data sets
one starting place for thinking about
analytic probability probably that you
can get from paper is the axioms of
probability the asymmet would probably
come from this guy called kalmograph who
I think of as being like a 1900s
Harrison Ford uh no right anyways so
what did Karl mcgov do uh before he got
into film industry
he came up with these three axioms of
probability and they're very meaningful
for two separate reasons one of his
contributions was he said if you assume
these three things we can derive all of
probability Theory
so once you feel that these three things
are true all the rules that we learn in
cs109 are going to then come from these
three rules there's this other thing
which is quite subtle did you know there
was a time when people didn't know if
probability of mathematics were the same
they thought maybe probably was just
this old different thing because it was
so unintuitive and they weren't sure
that all the rules of mathematics
applied so common graph also managed to
type probability Theory into the deeper
roots of mathematics and show how it was
in fact an instance of all the other
math that had been studied and he did
that going through counting and geometry
it's a really cool Deep dive if you're
curious about it but anyways these are
the three rules you could start out with
if you're learning probability though
I'm going to modify them a little bit
and say for our very first set of rules
for probability these are the three
rules that I present you the first two
axons and the third one is an identity
which is derived from the third Axiom
these are pretty easy to accept axioms
the first Axiom says every probability
is a number between zero and one that's
great you can't have less than zero
events happen and you can't have more
events happen than the experiments that
you've run probabilities have to be
between zero and one the second one p of
s equals one what's s
ample space yeah so what's this saying
saying the property of sample space is
one
yeah put that in words for me the
probability of something happening is
what yeah if you're going to say these
are all the outcomes
the probability of some outcome
happening is going to be one so it's a
little tautological I told you sample
space is all the things that could
happen and the probability of something
happening is one
how about this one what's this little C
up there is that like e raised to the
power of the speed of light
that's set notation for complement and
that's a fancy way of saying what's the
probability of e not happening
and this is saying the probability of e
not happening is one minus the
probability of e happening and we'll
prove this last one by the end of class
okay and do you guys feel pretty
comfortable about all those I say these
first two are pretty total logical I
like this third one I feel like you can
have some like deep shower thoughts
you're like this is kind of like saying
everything in the world is either a
potato or not a potato
anyways you can think about that nor
deeply okay
now that we know what a probability is
that zero number between zero and one
there's a special case where we can
derive probabilities rather easily using
counting and this special case of
analytical probability is called equally
likely outcomes
not all sample spaces are like this but
for some sample space if you looked at
any outcome it's just as likely as
another outcome so if you think about
flipping a coin we think about the heads
as being just as likely as the Tails if
you think about flipping two coins we
think about the outcome of getting ahead
on the first one ahead and the second
coin is just as likely as a tail on the
first coin and a tail on the second coin
all those outcomes are just as likely if
you roll a six-sided dice we think about
all the numbers as being equally likely
unless you use my pirate dice which
definitely always gives you a six but
that's not important right now we're
talking about equally likely events
if
every event is equally likely what's the
probability of any of the outcomes well
if there is size of s outcomes in the
sample space then if they're all equally
likely every single outcome must have
probably one divided by the number of
elements in the sample space let's take
coins there's two outcomes in the sample
space this is claiming that every
outcome has a one over two probability
if you took that a step further if you
cared about some event e and you want to
know the probability of E
it is the case that all you have to do
is count how many outcomes are there
from this experiment
and how many outcomes satisfy the event
I care about
and if you count those two numbers that
ratio is going to be the probability not
always true only true if the outcomes
are equally likely
here's an example that I want you to
debug
you're going to play the lottery what is
the sample space of playing the lottery
what are the outcomes
win or lose okay so if we use this logic
we can figure out that the probability
of winning
should be the size of the events face
divide by the size of this sample space
so the probability win is 50 percent
and why not what did I do wrong
yeah okay I'm gonna teach you something
and it only applies if your sample space
is equally likely is it just as likely
that you win as lose no definitely not
uh hilariously off okay great
but let me give you a situation that's
quite interesting to think about where
all the outcomes are equally likely I'm
going to consider rolling two dice let's
roll my two dice
see what I get
double sixes
a six and a three okay fine
how can I think about the probability of
the sum of these two dice lots of games
care about this and as I mentioned to
you last class A lot of probably theory
was invented by people who are horribly
addicted to gambling so they spent a lot
of time thinking about Dyson coins
so if I wanted to think about the
probability that these two dice sum up
to seven when I say summer to seven you
take the value of the first dice add the
value of the second dice that's its sum
you could think about this by taking
advantage of the fact that we think the
outcome space the sample space has
outcomes are equally likely
so here is that all the outcomes of
rolling two dice and here I'm going to
think of this as the value on the first
Dice and this is the value on the second
dice so there's a little diagram on the
right to help you so this is saying you
know let's say the yellow is the first
dice is a five and the green dice has a
two
so that's what this is saying
here's all the different outcomes you
know one one one two it's all the 36
different outcomes
are they all equally likely
you know it's hard to prove that two
things are equally likely when I say
prove that sample space are equally
likely it's hardly something that you
could do mathematically is often
something that you do intuitively be
like do I think it's every single one
here is somehow symmetrically equally
likely and we could talk about it it
turns out in this case they are in fact
equally likely every outcome here is
just as likely as all the others
now if we talked about caring not just
about the probability of the whole
sample space but the probability of a
particular event the two dice adds a
seven all we have to do is we have to
count the subset of the sample space
where the two dice sum to seven and how
many events are there well there's six
in one five and two four and three three
and four two and five one and six there
are six different outcomes where the sum
comes out to seven
so if you buy my argument that the
sample space is equally likely we can
know the probability of two dice
something to seven just by counting the
event space that's six divided by the
size of the sample space that's 36.
okay now
before I jump into things you might not
believe me you might say Chris I don't
think that this thing you claimed is
true is in fact true so the way I'd like
to convince you because I know you're
computer scientist is I'd say you know
okay I claim that probably Osama being
six is 0.166 repeating
but I can convince you by taking you to
the code so I wrote a little program
and this little program runs infinite
times okay not infinite times but pretty
close 10 million right
what is this program going to do it's
going to simulate that core definition
of probability 10 000 times
I'm going to run an experiment
The Experience going to return me the
dice total and the dice total is equal
to seven then I'm going to count that in
a running sum at the end I'm just going
to print the ratio of the number of
sevens I saw divide by the number of
trials that I ran
tqdm is this a cute thing that will give
me a progress bar as I go and then a
couple print statements running
experiment roll one dice roll the other
dice and then add them together and
rolling a dice just so you know I'm not
cheating is just going to give you a
random number that is one two three four
five or six this is also just a chance
for me to show you guys some python
um if any of this seems unfamiliar to
you besides the TQ GM then maybe the
python review session would be a good
thing to go to okay should we run this
whoa
whoa okay my computer is like taking a
moment to decide if it wants to run it
I've noticed if I put in that charger
that it gets unhappy but if I put in
this charger it's like I'm gonna go so
fast new Max man they're supposed to I
got like I'm gonna have the fastest Mac
in the world and then it freezes
okay terminal new Terminal A little bit
of time for you guys to think about what
I'm doing so I'm going to run this pi oh
come on
too much suspense for everybody
python yay simulate okay running it and
this is what tqdm it does this oh isn't
that so cute and it's like telling you
how many it does okay so I'm running 10
million and after I run 10 million the
ratio that it gives you is
0.166541 and somebody out there is like
whoa Chris was right and somebody else
is like ah no you're not you said it'd
be one 0.166 repeating and that's not
and why is it not you guys can just all
say it out loud
what you think I'm wrong number
seven yeah
this is the probability that two dice
add up to seven there's six outcomes
that have that
where the comment next to it oh
uh well I used to have a different demo
uh yeah
danger of comments eh okay
so
um
but somebody has to tell me why is this
number not 0.16666 repeating yes
because we do go to Infinity I went to
10 million no but you're exactly right
10 million is not even close to Infinity
but the closer I got to Infinity the
closer this would get to the true answer
so the more I run this will approach
0.166666 that's exactly right thank you
very much
okay so now that I've given you the
structure what if I asked you the
probability of the two dice equal to
I actually talk about this with a person
next to you because I want to make sure
that everybody is following along at
this point so if there's anything
confusing as a person next to you
otherwise what's the problem with these
two dice equal to
okay
that's about as long as I think it's
supposed to take
but maybe the question came up that you
want to ask everybody
any questions come up in about like 30
seconds
okay how do you approach this problem
we have to say all the outcomes are
equally likely count the sample space
and then count count the event space
sample space is the same there's still
36 outcomes but what is the event space
now
the size of the event space is one
one yeah it's a set with a single item
which is that item see the advanced
space is all of the single item and that
size of the end space is one so that
your probability is one divided by 36
that's the chance of getting sum of dice
equal to two
I want to talk about something which is
going to be so helpful for your problem
sets
it turns out I gave you one sample space
but there's different ways that smart
people could have constructed sample
spaces it just turns out I gave us the
one that set us up for success
let me tell you about other sample
spaces you could have set up for the
exact same experiments you could have
said I don't care about ordering I just
care about the set of outcomes so you
want to say like you know you got a two
and a five but I'm not going to say
which dice gave you the two and which
dice gave you the five in that case a
two five is not different from a five
two
that's a reasonable way of talking about
the set of outcomes of your experiment
here is a different way of expressing
all the outcomes of experiment you could
say Chris there are 11 different
outcomes the sum could be two the sum
could be three the sum could be four
some could be five those are all the
outcomes of your experiment of rolling
two dice
there is a problem though let's say you
chose that last one
you say the sample space well actually
you can't get a sum of one
but whatever
and ah but like still wrong
in this case you know you'd say the
outcomes are two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve and
then you say you're probably if your
event is the size of the event space
divided so the sample space and you get
like one divided by eleven and that's
not even close to 0.116 that we got when
we calculate or zero point was the right
answer
0.166 repeating
yeah that thing
so what's gone wrong here it's a valid
sample space it's just not the case that
the outcomes are equally likely it's not
just as likely to get a 7 as a two the
seven is much more likely than the two
so this though a valid sample space is
not one where the outcomes are equally
likely so you can't really use it to
come up with probabilities does that
make sense
that one's a little bit more obvious
this is the most subtle one and I want
to talk about it because it'll help you
all avoid a mistake on the problem set
midterms Etc
if you think about the dyes as
indistinct and you don't really care
about which one gave you numbers you
just care about the set of outcomes it
is a different outcome space so here's
the whole sample space there's a one one
one two but in this sample space a 2 1
is not different from a one two and a
three one is not different from a one
three does that make sense
every Alchemy experiment is represented
here
but in this case it also turns out that
the outcome space is not equally likely
and again if we want to say the
probability that the two dice are seven
we would get three divided by 20 which
is closer to the right answer but still
wrong
and it's still wrong because this sample
space is not equally likely
you're like wait why why is this one not
equally likely but the other one is
somebody
when you have two dice that are equal to
the same value you have doubles
um those are counted once but when you
have one two versus two one those are
kind of half as often as they actually
hear yes so if you want to it's easier
to argue that things are not equally
likely in the sample space you just need
to give two outcomes and show that
they're different and those two outcomes
that you've printed out are different
the chance of getting a 1-1 is half as
likely as getting a one two there's two
ways of getting one two the first ice
could be one the second dice could be a
two
or the other way around
um whereas a one one there's just one
way of getting it so this outcome space
looks equally likely but it is not
so really tricky you want to come up
with outcome services that are equally
likely and the best way to do that is to
think about all of your out your
elements as being distinct if you think
about all your elements as being
distinct you will more often than not
end up in equally likely outcome spaces
I have the dreaded cows and pigs problem
for you this is hard it is going to be
difficult to think through but if you
can do this this is showing that you
fully are getting the complexities and
Nuance of setting up equally likely
outcome spaces it doesn't sound that
hard I have four cows and three pigs in
a toy box
I will pull three of these toys out
every Toya is equally likely on every
draw
and I want to know what's the chance I
end up with one cow and two pigs
I'm gonna give you guys a few options
for how to approach this but then I'm
going to let you choose which one you
want to approach it with
your first step in accounting
probability problem is to choose your
sample space how are you going to
represent the outcomes of an experiment
here and here I think you have two
different choices you can think of your
outcomes as ordered or unordered
and you can think of each cow as being
distinct from the other cows or you can
think of every cow as being indistinct
from the other cows
and it'll be a Choose Your Own Adventure
Two of which will lead to bad times and
two of which will lead to Good Times so
here is one
you think of cow one as different from
pig two and pig two is different from
pig three but you think about a choice
as being unordered and who I wouldn't
think cow one being the third thing
would be a different outcome here
unordered indistinct would be two cows
one Pig and three cows would be as
examples of outcomes ordered is I care
about order it's different from this one
because I care that cow one came first
and then Pig two came first the second
and picked three came third and that
would be different than if Pig three
came first and cow one and then Pig two
even though it's the same set of
distinct items this one has order in My
outcome space and this one doesn't and
then indistinct and unordered would look
like this some of you guys are thinking
how can we have a choice isn't it one of
these is the right way
it's a beautiful piece of creativity in
this part of problem solving you get to
choose how you express your sample space
you could make this Choice all of these
are valid ways of articulating the
outcomes experiments it's just two of
them will lead to good answers
questions about that before we jump in
this is a meaty problem
think about this here's a meta task
while you're thinking about it you're
going to choose your path but then I
want you to remember what are the tasks
of this counting thing Define your
sample space count the size of the
sample space and then count the subset
of the sample space that satisfy the
event you care about okay and while you
think about that I will write down the
thing we care about so we have four cows
so four cows
three pigs
and we are going to draw three and we
want the probability of one cow and two
pigs
how can you tell I spent a little bit
too many times with uh toy farm animals
but it turns out this is a very deep
probability problem is able to pull from
that okay
talk about it with your friend think
about it explore
contemplate
okay
not enough time
but
the way I see this this is the first
time you're seeing a problem with this
complexity we'll do it mostly together
now that you understand how deep it is
but the real goal is this is one of the
most important problems from today
because the real goal is if you can
understand the process of how to come
into an answer here it will be very
helpful for you going forward
so four choices
um
did anyone go down this path you could
just raise your hand
a few folks did anyone go down this path
not many folks anyone go down this path
couple folks anyone go down this path
a couple folks okay
so
one of
the things that we should just do if you
want to choose a path is you want to
decide are the outcomes equally likely
now
it's easier to show that outcomes are
not equally likely
um than it is to show that outcomes are
equally likely let me show you one
example let's take this outcome space so
we're going to not think of anything as
distinct and we're just going to count
how many unordered elements we get
here are two different outcomes in that
space
three cows and three pigs
are they equally likely so you have four
cows and three pigs in your bag are you
just as likely to get three pigs as you
are to get three cows
yeah the outcomes here are not equally
likely so we can't use the space even if
we can count fine we can't use the
equally likelihood formula and something
similar here you have cow cow and pig
pig are two different outcomes in this
space and those two are not equally
likely
it turns out between these two choices
they're both correct
there are two different paths to an
answer and they both have equally likely
outcome spaces even though here we think
of that things as unordered here we
think about them as ordered
let's think about the first one the
sample space is all the ways you could
choose three elements how many things
are in this sample space so I have seven
Choice seven toys and I want to figure
out all the different subsets unordered
of three that I can choose from my seven
and I'm putting this line here because
I'm going to count my sample space here
and then I'm going to count my event
space over here so how many things are
in that sample space
seven choose three this is not talking
at all about this event this is just the
number of outcomes so the number of
outcomes of the experiment
is well there's seven outcome there's
seven animals and we're choosing three
of them
that's getting us pretty close we have
one final task to do count how many of
these outcomes
are of the nature that you have one cow
and two pigs
you're like Chris you never taught me
that counting task ah but I taught you
the most fundamental rules of counting
Counting by or counting by steps
and you can use those most fundamental
rules of counting to come up with either
a set of steps or an or that would get
you to having one cow and two pigs
so can somebody think about a two-step
experiment that would get us to one cow
and two pigs
was that a
I think you know it I think you know it
yeah guessing good uh could you pick
like any one cow out of the four
thousand that's step one
yeah exactly that's exactly right so
Step One is it's like I'm gonna take my
four cows I'm gonna choose one cow and
step two is I'm gonna take my three pigs
and I'm gonna choose
two of them and there's a two-step
experiment the number of outcomes in the
first step doesn't change how many
outcomes are in second step and that's
the Only Rule you need in order to have
a two-step experiment and will this two
steps lead to a one cow two Pig combo
you bet it will so it satisfies all the
things we want so the two steps one you
have your four cows
and you're going to choose one of them
we multiply because the step rule of
counting says we can multiply and then
you had your three pigs and you're going
to choose two of them
and if you did this math you would get
the right answer for the probability of
getting these one cows and two pigs
so just to put what we had on the board
up here you know the um
oh sorry I started with ordered here's
the unordered one
sample space is seven choose three
there's 35 different outcomes the event
space there's one if four choose one
ways of choosing your cow and there's
three choose two ways of choosing your
pigs and there's 12 outcomes there so
your probability is 12 divided by 35.
what if you thought about things as
ordered and distinct
well now if you think about it you have
to construct a sample space where you
care about ordering
if you want to construct the sample
space
it matters what is first second and
third
so the argument here is my sample space
there's seven animals for the choice of
the first thing in a sample then there's
six animals remaining that you could
choose to be the second one and there's
five animals remaining that you could
choose to be the third so seven times
six times five equals 210 outcomes if
you think about things as being ordered
now
the event space is going to be a little
bit harder to calculate there's three
different there's three different cases
where you end up
um
sorry this should say pick a cal as
either first second or third so there's
either the cow is first second or third
if the cow is first
you have four choices for the cow then
this is going to be a pig there's three
choices for a pig then there's two
choices left for another Pig in this
case the cow is second so three choices
for your pig the cow is second you have
four choices there and then for the
remaining Pig there's only two pigs left
to choose from in the case where the cow
is third three choices for your pig two
choices for the remaining Pig and then
four choices for the cow that's third
why can't I just add those up
or rule of counting I'm saying my
outcomes can either come from this case
or this case or this case it must be the
case that they're mutually exclusive why
do I know they're Mutual exclusive why
is it not possible for an outcome here
to be the same as an outcome here
or one cow yeah whatever I type up the
the step in which you take it as matters
yeah so here all the cows are first and
here are all the cows are second so
there can't be any overlap exactly okay
so we can add these three numbers up you
get 72 over 210 and very happy we can do
our like you got 12 over 35 it's the
exact same answer no matter if you
thought of it as order or distinct so if
we go back to these two choices these
two were passed to happiness and these
were too past to like some version of
happiest but happiness where you're
wrong on this problem uh and what do we
notice is the same about these in both
these cases we thought about your
animals as being distinct
were they actually distinct when I posed
the problem no you made them distinct
and you can do that when solving these
problems okay question and then question
oh you know I can
um I I like know we can because
it's because I'm saying there's a
two-step experiment to end up with the
construction of one cow and two picks
the first step is you pick your cow the
next step is you pick your two pigs and
there are two different steps but if you
put those two steps together you end up
with one cow two pigs and because the
outcome of one step doesn't change the
number of outcomes in the second step we
can just multiply we can use the step
rule of counting so step one choose your
cow step two choose your two pigs this
is the number of outcomes in step one
this is number of outcomes step two we
multiply those numbers good question
yes
72 over 210 versus 12 over 35 is like a
multiplication factor of three factorial
is that because it's like three spots to
fill and for example if we were to do
four spots of before factorial where is
that yeah no no I think that's exactly
right so you're saying if you multiply
the numerator and denominator by six or
three factorial you would get this
numerator into this denominator and I
think you're exactly right for any one
unordered combination there's three
factorial ways that you can mix it up so
there's three factorial times more
things in the sample space here
fantastic yes
I'm playing again how we've made the
decision that it has to be distinct how
interesting we just did it we're just
like I got my couch I'm gonna think of
them as like their own little unique
butterflies
should look different if we choose
indistinct instead ah so if you chose
indistinct
you can do your counting but you'll get
it wrong because the outcomes are not
equally likely because the outcomes are
not equally likely you can't solve this
probably a problem using uh Counting
so because we knew that it was not
equally likely to get a cow's Pig we
know that we have to think of them each
as distinct yeah if you want your
outcomes to be distinct because cows and
pigs are not equally likely in these two
cases where you thought in the
indistinct it led to outcomes that were
not equally likely
do we mean like each of the cows is
distinct
stick for one another so you can tell a
different between two and pig three and
you can tell the difference between cow
one cow two cow three can you tell the
difference between cow one Pig two
yeah definitely definitely and here you
can think of the difference between cows
and pigs but just you can't tell the
difference between those two cows
it's like we gave the name you're like
you're Daisy and you're muddy or like
whatever and so they have their own
unique names
okay question uh how can we tell that
like
um looking at them as distinct will have
like people like the outcomes
I wish I had a clean answer you I've
heard this question many times it's a
very good question it's like how can we
convince ourselves that these are going
to be equally likely
the truth is that distinct often leads
to equally likely but to really prove it
it would take like a deep symmetry
argument
but you know I guess that's my argument
here they're symmetric like there's no
reason that one of these outcomes should
be more likely than any other outcomes
and I would just have to argue that to
you as a reasonable person
so I would say that it's easier
or rather we should always choose the
distinct options
yeah if you went down this path it's not
hard it's just you'll get the wrong
answer because they're not equally
likely yeah good good questions
okay
major key here make your items distinct
if possible to get equally likely sample
space outcomes because you need equally
likely sample space outcomes if you want
to use counting and I think about this
as a trick a pro tip that you should use
with high probability
okay let's think about another problem
five card poker hand we talked about on
last class that there's 52 to five
different hands from a normal deck of
cards
of that a subset have this special
semantic meaning that we call a straight
A straight is that you have the values
of the cards are in order the suits can
be anything you want but the values must
be in order
now all cards are already distinct so we
don't have to worry about that
complexity
and we've already talked about how a
hand of cards there's 52 choose five of
those how could you count the subset of
the 50 choose choose five hands
which are a straight
so that's my question for you guys and I
do want to give you guys a second to
think about it because these are meaty
problems are worth thinking about so how
could you now if I Define the sample
space for you how could you use step
rules of counting or the oral rule of
County to construct all the events that
lead to five cards in a row having
consecutive values
okay I know never enough time
now what I hoped you would have gotten
to by that point maybe is not the full
answer but to realize that my task here
is to come up with a series of steps
that if you were to follow these steps
would end up constructing all of the
different sets that are possible from 52
cards or sorry straights that are
possible for 52 cards and to use a step
rule of counting we just need to come up
with these sets that lead to that
outcome and each outcome should show up
exactly once in our Construction
so what are steps that could construct
all of the outcomes here
yes an idea to get started
well I guess the first step would be
picking one card out of the 52 to get it
started yeah but do you need to know the
suit or do you just want to know the
value
um
okay so you're saying pick one value to
get us started do you want to pick the
lowest value or do you want to pick the
highest value
that's not it okay well let's look at if
it doesn't matter then let's pick the
lowest value so we'll pick the smallest
number in our set that's step one
how many choices are there for picking
the smallest value
two can you can start straight with the
two you can start at three start with
four five six seven eight nine ten or
Jack right jack queen king Ace no you
can only get to ten
yeah yeah no no
we don't count that as a straight
playing poker hands so two three four
five six seven eight nine ten there's
nine choices
for the value of the first card
it's like I'm teaching counting at
Stanford and I can't even go from nine
to ten
are we sure two
no you can't start with it oh oh you can
start with the Nays okay you're right so
it is 10 right
yeah as2345 counts as a straight we're
not learning poker here we're learning
Counting
okay
at this point do you have a full hand
no you've only defined one value
once you know that let's say without
loss of generality that you've chosen
your lowest value to be a two
we now need to choose the value of this
card
but wait do we
we already know it's going to be a three
and how about the value of this card
four five six so once you've chose a
number are we done
someone thinks we're not
really doesn't it can we also get a four
or a five after the first card and then
get a three later ah that's a very good
point we don't care about ordering here
so we don't think about any card as
being first or last so like a two
followed by three is gonna be the same
as a three followed by a two so in this
52 2's uh five where in this world where
we don't think about ordering it's not
the you know 52 times 51 times 50 that
would have meant that they're ordered
cards very very cool so your event space
should match your sample space so that
means we're going to construct things
are unordered
such a good question
okay so they're unordered once you've
chosen one card we know the value of all
the other cards are we done is this just
10 divided by 52 choose five
no because I've just constructed values
I haven't chosen suits
I haven't told you that this one's a
heart and this one's a diamond this
one's a and I need to choose suits
because in this sample space all my
cards have suits so in this event space
which is supposed to be a subset all my
cards also have to have suits so let's
choose it how can I choose a suit for
this card
the two
yeah there's four choose one fun fact
four choose one is four
so there's four choices for the suit of
card one how about for the next card
but isn't there just yeah are there
three suits left are there four suits
left
yeah because it doesn't matter what suit
the two is the three can be any suit
okay there's four choices for the next
and then four choices for the third card
four choices for the suit of the fourth
card and four choices for suit of the
last card I sometimes when I do this
like to write arrows be like choose
starting number choose the suit of the
first card third second card third card
fourth card fifth card um but this is
ten times four times four times four
times four times four
will that construct us a set that is a
straight
oh am I missing something
yeah I have an extra four
no no no no no no I have the right and
finally
why because there's one four for every
card and there's five cards
you have to choose the suit of every
single card
okay so your choice was I want to choose
the lowest number in the street
so maybe in this case the lowest number
in the straight is a six in this case
the lowest number is a two and so let's
do this your lowest number can be an ace
you can be a two it can be three it can
be four can five can be six seven eight
nine and it can be a ten so there's ten
choices for your lowest number
and then once you know your lowest
number the values of the next cards are
already set for you
if you tell me your list number six I
know the old ones are 7 8 9 10 because I
know it's a straight
yes
wait how many strings we can get as
opposed to the problem that it's getting
a straight
but this we counted how many straights
you could get but you divide that by
5225 then you get a probability
so this ratio is the probability because
of equally likely to outcome spaces
okay one question in the back one
question
the deck every time you draw One
it is because in this sample space when
you do 50 choose two five it doesn't
allow you to choose the same card twice
so when you do choosing you're not
getting the same thing multiple Heights
it's not with replacement
it's very good
okay
fantastic something think about here it
is in the slides but we've already done
it on the board
um one couple Pro tips if you find this
hard if you find it hard to come up with
an answer just write one example of one
outcome and then try and make sure that
you convince yourself that every outcome
is equally likely and then you construct
after you've counted the sample space
then you can count your event space and
the probability of your event if they're
equally likely is the ratio of those two
numbers
okay
uh I'm gonna leave straight flush up
here oh actually maybe this is
interesting a straight flush is when all
the cards also have the same suit so
maybe they're all hearts or they're all
clubs or they're all diamonds or they're
all Spades
so some people don't consider it to be a
straight if it's also a straight flush
so what's the probability of being a
straight but not a straight flush
I just want to show you in this case
again the sample space is the same
we're just going to try and count how
many hands are straights but not
straight flushes
and this is just an example of okay if
you count the number of straights
and you don't want to include the number
of straight flushes you can just
subtract out how many straight flushes
there are so the event space will be all
the straights minus the straights which
also happen to be straight flushes
choose your value and then choose one
suit
and you don't have to choose any other
suits if you're making a straight flush
because there's only one choice
this number is much smaller than this
number so if this was your event space
it'd be a much smaller probability than
this if this is your event space
straight flushes are much less likely
than straights okay
so
key tip if you're given a problem that
looks like an equally likelihood
probability problem you want to start by
defining your sample space what's the
outcomes write a couple of those out and
then Define what the event space is and
then get to counting and counting is
awesome and going to use things like the
step rule of counting or the or rule of
counting
okay my final example
n chips are manufactured
and we're going to assume that exactly
one is defective
you're going to test some set I'm going
to not test every single one of my end
chips instead I'm going to test K of
them and then I'm going to wrap and then
I'm going to see what's the probability
that the single defective chip was in my
K chosen ones
because if the single defective chip was
in my Cade chosen ones then I catch it
and if it's not in my K chosen once to
test then I don't catch it which is sad
times
so the question is could you figure out
this probability I'm going to let you
guys think about but I'm also going to
combine it with your two minute
pedagogical pause so I'll give you some
time to think about but I'm also going
to give you a little bit more time so
you can go to the bathroom as you like
uh whatever you need
sorry okay
okay yeah
okay
I know I've thrown three pretty hard
questions at you but I have this
pedagogical idea that if I give you lots
of examples when you get to your problem
sets things will be much easier so if I
give you a breadth of examples even
though they're hard if you're willing to
work through them it'll leave you in a
good place
this is another instance of a problem we
have N Chips one is defective we're
going to choose K randomly to test
that's out of the end so K must be
smaller than n and what's the
probability that you in your test set
you happen to get the defective group
I'm going to use this as a chance to
give you guys some more Pro tips let's
assume this is quite hard
one thing you can do that's adding
complexity or one thing that's adding
complexity is these variables n and K
are making things a little bit harder
than they need to be and if you find a
problem like this hard give concrete
numbers so let's say n is seven
so you have seven chips
and I'm just making this up so that I'm
making a concrete so that when you're
thinking it through you could also think
about it with concrete numbers let's set
K to be three
and obviously when you give your answer
you're going to have to give the general
one where n could be any large number
and K is any number that's smaller than
n but by thinking about seven three
doesn't it become a little bit easier
okay so let's think about this what are
the steps to solving a problem like this
we want a probability
but if we can find a way to construct a
sample space that's equally likely we
can solve this problem using Counting
so your first step would be can I figure
out how I can do a sample space where
things are equally likely
so you know I could think there's N
Chips
and I could choose maybe three of them
in order and I could say There's 7 times
6 times 5 different ways of getting
three chips in order thinking about them
as distinct
or I could say I want to choose a subset
I'm thinking of the sample space so I'd
say there's seven chips and we're going
to choose three of them that's my sample
space all the outcomes of my experiment
I don't think you could use bucketing
for this one
so which one do you guys like
which sample space and maybe we should
draw an example of them
so in the first example a sample space
we're thinking of them as ordered so
like you choose chip seven first
or you know we'll call I'll say you know
C7 for chip seven and then you choose C1
next for the second ship and then you
choose C2 and we think about this as
being ordered if you think about it as
just the choose operation your sample
space would be like C7
C1 C2
it's the same grid of options you had
when we had the pigs and cows you think
of your chips as distinct or not
distinct and you can think about your
outcomes as being ordered or not ordered
but we learned from that experiment that
it's better to think about them as
distinct
and in that case it turned out didn't
matter if we thought about that it's
ordered or not ordered yes
yeah there is one thing I'm going to
tell you that exactly one chip is
defective oh you're saying okay you're
saying that um ah you're saying that
like one of these could be the defective
chip
like I should have a special symbol for
the defective one
okay so it could be like chip seven chip
one and the defective one yeah yeah good
good so there's if n is seven there's
six healthy chips and one defective one
very good
helpful clarification
okay what's our sample space what are
all the outcomes of the experiment of
choosing three to test
okay seven choose three I heard a lot of
people say seven choose three that's the
size of the outcome space
if you think about any one of those
outcomes it's like it's got three chips
and a set
so there's seven possible chips you
could have chose from you choose three
and in this case if you wanted to write
it more generally you would write and
shoot you wouldn't write seven and three
you would write add in k
you know there's
N Chips and you're gonna choose K of
them
those are all the outcomes but it
doesn't describe the event space in the
event space is the outcomes where you
happen to get the defective shift
so every outcome in the event space
better have that defective chip in it
so can we come up with a step a set of
steps that will come up with an outcome
that does have the defective chip in it
yeah
to choose seven choose two and multiply
by seven choose one
so okay but what are those two steps
two would basically be choosing two
non-defective ones okay so choose you
have okay you have seven chips and you
want to choose two that are not
defective but it's not the case that all
seven are non-defective
so your first step is to choose your two
non-defective ones right
yeah and particularly it's n minus one
because there's n minus one chips that
are not defective
and you want to choose
K minus one of those
six choose two so there's six
non-defective chips and you're going to
choose two of them
there's three chips in this set that
last Chip is going to be defective
so we're going to choose one defective
chip
out of how many defective chips
yeah and guess what one choose one is
and guess what one multiply by anything
is
just one bye bye
okay you guys got it
that's absolutely the right answer
okay
um so the sample space there's n choose
K different ways you could choose the
chips to test
of those the ones where you caught the
chip you cared about you could use the
step rule of counting to construct all
of those outcomes first choose your
defective chip and then choose your
non-defective ones in our case we did
this in the other order doesn't matter
no it doesn't matter if you choose your
defectives and then you're defected
you're in your non-defectives afterwards
okay
now for those of you guys who are
interested in not just having this
formula but trying to make it a little
more simple you could take this formula
and apply it to the actual combinations
formula and this is what that would give
you and the same thing on the bottom you
can apply the actual combinations
formula and if you're willing to sit
with this for a second if you do all
your canceling it gives you K divided by
n
what
huh
so
How Could You Is there a way you could
have just gotten to this answer a little
bit faster
one way of thinking about it
is to think you've got N Chips here so
I'm going to draw my N Chips
this is not that important by the way if
you see the problem one way that's
sufficient but this is just kind of fun
here's my end chips of which one is
defective
it's kind of like
you're gonna have
case shots at these
oh wait oh sorry let me try that again
I got my formulation wrong here's my end
chips and of this I'm going to choose
the K uh that are
uh the ones that you test
now imagine we're going to place the
defective chip over here
so what are all the different places
where you could put the defective chip
like if you count the different
locations where I put the defective chip
how many different places could I I'm
gonna I'm gonna first put all my chips
there then I'm going to circle out all
the ones that I'm testing and my now I'm
going to imagine I'm going to throw the
defective chip somewhere on one of these
weird weird construction I'm just being
playful here the other answer is the
more straightforward one
where like imagine the defective chip
was a dart and I was throwing it at all
the chips it could land on any of these
n places right and they're all equally
likely so you can imagine there's n
outcomes of this super weird experiment
in the sample space there's n outcomes
of which
if the defective chip hits here did I
catch it
no because it wasn't in this tested set
if it lands here did I catch it
how many of these outcomes will I catch
there's K of them
so K divided by n there's n places I can
throw my defective chip of which K will
lead to me catching it such a weird
weird way of setting up a sample space
but hey it works and it gets the right
answer
okay
yeah because
it does suggest that you can be mindful
because if you're a really creative and
thoughtful you could have saved yourself
a lot of math but at the end of the day
you know these two things do give if you
did the math you get the same thing in
both ways but you're right the sample
space here is really large if you had to
save this whole thing in memory
that would be a huge problem if you had
to save all these outcomes of memory not
a problem at all
okay
um
this is a little bit less important so I
want to spend a little bit less time on
it actually I'm going to leave it there
just for something to review if you're
curious
um in fact though actually
we are out of time so this is probably
the place where I should pause and let
us continue but I did promise one thing
that I want to make sure I am good on so
if you have a moment I told you by the
end of today's class I would do
something that has never been done in
the history of the world you guys ready
for it
see this deck of cards you ready
I'm Shuffling it I'm Shuffling it once
not once I'm Shuffling it twice
wait for it a third time
and then
let's just do it really fast four
five
six the reason I shuffle it six times is
there's a professor at Stanford who's
proved that using a cool thing is chaos
theory once you shuffle a deck of cards
with 52 cards six times every ordering
is equally likely
ladies and gentlemen this ordering of
cards
never been seen
tree of the world no one has ever seen
this exact ordering never ever and I am
so certain of it
you could get this by thinking about
sample spaces and event spaces but
basically how many orderings are there
of cards there's 52 factorial 52
factorial is so bloody large that even
if you think about a sample space of
people shuffling over the history of the
world no one has ever seen this set of
cards before ladies and gentlemen have a
fantastic weekend we'll see you guys
back on Monday